you had to give all these monologues you
spoke a lot oh god do you miss that
jensen wants to ask me he was he was
being very polite but he asked me one
day he goes okay i gotta ask you this
so bob and i were wondering
how come
when you when you're doing your
off-camera dialogue you're perfect
everything's right and then we turn
around onto you it takes you three takes
four takes to get it
and one time he asked me this when he
was had a couple of drinks so he was
nicely lubed up
and it was at three in the morning or
something stupid
and i said listen
you're the lead
you're basically talking bollocks
they give me a story that they think is
funny they give me lines that they think
is incredibly funny when they've written
it on paper i now have to read that find
a way to believe it and find a way to
make it actually mean something
otherwise i'm halfway through going
it means nothing to me
so
i said that's the reason why i'm
carrying the bloody plot or i'm carrying
the cut the counter plot or i'm carrying
the c story or i'm carrying it's it's
for how many years i did eight you did
eight seasons and don't listen i'm
telling you i love those guys i love
those guys with all my heart yeah
absolutely yeah ups and downs i mean the
the the thing at the end was the weird
thing what was that weird thing to do
with the boys had nothing to do with
anything else they didn't ask you to
come back well no it was worse than that
it was kind of tacky
it was
it was like well we don't think we have
enough money to pick up your option next
year
are you serious well because they were
working out how to do what they were
going to do with the story that they
needed to continue beyond you know into
the 13th and 14th seasons and rest
and i think a particular showrunner
remained nameless um was trying to kill
me for about four or five years and it
was just funny because i kind of knew
because i knew the rest of the writers
but i didn't care about that wasn't the
problem i had the point being is i went
from being a guest star that refused to
sign a contract for five years
to now i'm three years i mean warner's
put me on the poster before my deal was
done they put me on the video box they
were just like well you can't sort of
ignore it
and then it was like take it or leave it
and i think it was majorly about getting
the boys out on a friday more than
anything else
which is smart i mean for god's sakes
they've been working for you know 10 11
12 years at the time